[Music]
in liquid courage news submitted by
someone got Bo oh yeah
no just my breath how did you know
because I wanted to go here and he's
carrying the set yeah David always
smells good yeah I don't get Bo yeah
oh that's a lie I have gone beyond
before it but it's just a long time you
know that a church volleyball game oh
wow four [ __ ] six hours in the Sun a
drunk man becomes the first person in
history to survive swimming across the
hoover dam and he was drunk by the way
great Wow Oh a drunk man in history he's
a drunk man who swam across the Hoover
Dam is so you gotta get drunk first
first time someone survived that that's
crazy wait cuz a lot of drunk guys try
to swim and they dies are not they're
drunk but yeah people have tried to swim
it let's get [ __ ] up this weekend and
let's all go the Hoover Dam
did you get sucked you get sucked into
the bottom part or the actual water suck
you out and then the turbines turn on
and then you get caught up and in like
exactly
wait what that's a thing turbine oh no
[ __ ]
luckily when Aaron from the UK jumped in
he there were only there was only one
turbine that was working so ate among or
nine of them were off because a turbine
stuck in the water right is that that's
how they use the electricity powder for
the water pressures yeah so this 28 year
old man you went to Vegas for a bachelor
party
that's hey I'm during the the vacation
him and his drunk buddies they somehow
ended up at the Hoover Dam where as one
does yeah of course that's a dry but
yeah that's never happened to me
drunken baby trying to come to LA or
something I don't know how do we get
here right no we were saying that they
were so wild that they made the hangover
hangover movie look team yeah no
everyone says
unless you had a [ __ ] tiger in your
room bro shut the [ __ ] up
yeah everyone would be one up that an
elephant no these cats dolphin these
cats they cry they think that because
like in the morning they turned their
mattress up and put it up against the
the window so that the Sun would stay
out that they're that crazy [ __ ] it's
like that guy doesn't see it's like
these type of stories that I don't like
hearing from people you know it's like
this is what I did is I basically been
trying to blow themselves up you know I
mean it's not a story that we all enjoy
this is me having to listen how awesome
you are you know like whatever how
badass you are
yeah yeah drive the Hoover Dam you get
[ __ ] nerds I mean you know go take a
picture by the Hoover Dam all right it's
like someone that's like dude I was in
Vegas and I stayed up past midnight dude
all bad well I mean this is an
impressive beat though in fact I he
actually survived this because people
have died in trying to do this they had
all the turbines turned on but what a
[ __ ] yeah that gives a [ __ ] man turn
all the turbines on you get it back in
yeah let's have this conversation I
don't know if it's accomplishment
because all I think of is like that's
irresponsible
skydiving is an accomplishment but this
is like mmm that's true I do a lot of
dangerous [ __ ] she coulda tested that
yeah but I look at this and go that's
irresponsible buddy it's the most
dangerous thing you've done I don't know
the things that I do I don't feel like
they're dangerous that's why I do them
damn that's better answer really is good
I get scared like I would probably go
out jump off a 20-foot cliff but not a
34 40 foot okay like into water racing
yeah
your your Wildman so I don't know I mean
I'll do normal things you know like but
I know it's just relative to wear a red
jumpsuit and equip neighborhood and I'm
pretty good yeah so Aaron said that when
they were all there that they were just
standing there like it has a damn when
he decided to say just [ __ ] and this is
after 37 hours of partying straight by
the way and so he was just like you know
what [ __ ] I'm gonna jump in so he
jump in all of his friends are all
cheering him on he ends up swimming
across and then for some reason he
decided to swim back and then when he
came back cops were there waiting for
him dang so it's illegal to jump in oh
yeah cause is so dangerous yeah so he
was fined three hundred and thirty
dollars and then released that's it but
if this guy if this guy was a groom that
was partly the biggest selfish move
because you're about to get married
you're about to possibly die and leave
your wife forever future wife I mean it
doesn't say if he was a groom or not
Guzman because it's like you ruined the
[ __ ] vibe of the wedding cuz you died
well now it's like we've been party for
it's great dude now we have to cut this
thing early I got 36 hours yeah
thanks a lot you [ __ ] [ __ ] me too
yeah thank you yourself why don't you
we're gonna go 45 hard so which one do
you guys think is earring the one on the
right yeah dude bigger one cuz he needs
all the [ __ ] swim you know you
actually did it with his sneakers on -
yeah it was this Aaron Aaron there's an
arrow where is he now partying it up I'm
not sure I didn't really take a good
look at this photo to figure out where
he is
can you imagine can you imagine being a
Vegas local and then working there like
everybody is there to let off some steam
and do things that they will never do at
home so they come into your town and go
let's [ __ ] up this town it is like what
uh fine well sure that's a lot of people
around the world think of American soup
because they're so rowdy when I was in
Italy
Lawrence there were these group of
Americans that they look like during
college and they're just it's always
those college-age Fox
I like shut up you're giving us a bad
name the best [ __ ] is when you go to
Vegas with the youtubers have you guys
done that no real youtubers right you me
like yeah we're adults but but I mean
like you go to Vegas with youtubers and
like like you said they do things that
they don't do normally at home like for
example they [ __ ] go outside and talk
to people yeah Michael for them it's
like whoa have a conversation yeah
you're walking around with a drink in
your hand yeah like for them it's like I
like it when I always see them do the
where they try to do the video with a
living of life really well and they had
their friend hold it I still haven't
gone there insect
it looks like boring as [ __ ] looks like
a road trip a boring road trip in a
station wagon with my whole family and a
screaming baby that's why I want to go
because it was one of those things I
missed out on
I saw the Grand Canyon American
experiences that then I don't capture
but take me to Vegas I'm gonna [ __ ]
blow for the poker tables baby let's go
I lose all my money tonight that's it
huh I'm getting it back that's what's
gonna happen when I think about gambling
I start salivating when I get excited
yeah buddy so this is when he's finished
swimming and the cops arrested him and
here's another photo of that hey I don't
have a gambling problem
because yeah I'm responsible I go you
know what this this time I'm gonna pay
I'm gonna play with $3,000 I don't go
into the bank account and chase my loss
you you have a problem but you're
responsible with your problem
yes I say I know I got a problem so let
me control it by blowing as much money
as I want up to this limit yeah you have
your limits but you do blow it yes
there's times when we should have
stopped but you're like ah this stack
[ __ ] it all in right here again get it
out of the system so it's like you have
so let's say you go there with like
$10,000 right but every day you gotta
have a day limit so let's say you're
there for three days that's $10,000 a
day no no that is $10,000 for the whole
weekend oh please going cheap you're
going cheap and then you go $3,000 for
the day can I just have that money and
then you'll just pretend that you want
people that blow that kind of money at
the temple they go to the church and
they donate they blow it on hurricane
relief ten thousand dollars for the
hurricane relief there's a lot I know I
have a have a problem so I have to use
it it's but it I don't get the same
satisfaction if I give it to people at
least you have a handle on yeah which is
doesn't something cuter did you like you
know
hurricane Harvey happen you know Kevin
Hart he just called out a bunch of
people oh yeah like y'all I'm calling
out these dudes cuz y'all are so blessed
and I was like Hurricane Irma happened I
was like was Harvey so bad that Herman
didn't do nothing like it was like it's
not that bad it was just not good as
compared be bad I guess yeah it was bad
it's still bad water was still high
there's nine that like 15 million people
over it like like Harvey was so bad that
the other one and then they just
whenever happened they took it seriously
they're like get the [ __ ] out yeah and
they oh yeah because of Harvey yeah yeah
so anyways here's Aaron's ticket and
right here would you like to reuse
offense offense description factual
basis for charge jumping diving swimming
[ __ ] is that one from Oh from dams
spillways or other structures yeah
so that wasn't sick you don't wanna like
Vegas what it's because I don't feel
weird there no cuz the whole winter real
weirdos there yeah I feel I feel like
I'm accepted there like as long as you
have money people will make you feel
welcome there that's what a human being
should be like I like that I like these
because filled with fake [ __ ] which is
my favorite in the whole world yeah
everything's not readable yeah but
that's why it's the best fake titties
fake titties everywhere fake people like
everyone's weak walking around like
they're ballers they're faking it yeah
fake Wonderlab yeah everyone's weren't
suits like they [ __ ] can't be the
richest guys on earth Tuesday super sore
every suit it's the only suit yeah and
the richest guys look like bums do I
stop Steve that's funny you say that
because I saw Steve win in his own hotel
walking down the thing oh really he just
was wearing [ __ ] shorts and t-shirt
yep what you said like you just relax in
yeah and meanwhile like guys who are
pores [ __ ] like were three-piece suits
and [ __ ] yeah I saw I saw a guy like in
a tracksuit just like hit like adidas
warmups
he came onto the roulette table like put
20,000 down and then walked away lost at
all just lost it that's how you know
you're [ __ ] that's the people who are
rich they're already rich and people who
are probably want to feel rich it's just
it's you could walk over there you walk
over here there's so much food of every
culture and it's close by going around
the world and every day you can be lazy
and people accept you for that it's like
the most accepting place in the world
and there's cheap property there because
they built way too many houses there
they thought nobody wants it was living
where I [ __ ] and you can just just
gamble all day and no one looks at you
weird because you could smoke indoors
you could be like you could drink 24
hours you could do a lot of drugs and if
you have enough money no one's gonna
tell you not to the police will just
tell you to like chill out I hear Disney
music behind you
like it says dream so you could see all
these great circus acts and performers
of the high quality arts it's so awesome
day sponsored by Vegas traditionally
we're not done yet hold on and Cirque de
Soleil where people look right on each
other and [ __ ] hump each other it's
like basically sexual but they but it's
not sexual so you can get away with
going and taking your whole family with
you that's what I'm talking about what
I'm talking about that's the dream of it
in the person heirs that make you feel
like you're with Michael Jackson again
or you're just with you know fetal yeah
the Beatles or somebody like you all I
got to do is take a little bit of weed
and then you're like the Wayne Newton
guy comes out like mr. Las Vegas Obama
guy yeah what's up you sexy [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
want to follow us you could check out
all our [ __ ] links in the description
box below you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
that videos are up there
[Music]